have you spoken to Jordan and how is he
well it's so funny because wherever I go
people want to know how Jordan's doing
or no actually what they want to know is
why isn't Jordan with you right now and
I always say because I want to enjoy my
life yeah
um Jordan is and and this is true what's
amazing about Jordan schlansky is people
do these deep Dives on the Jordan
shlansky remotes and the adventures that
we've had together and they see that I
get irritated with him and a lot of
people think well it's got to be an act
and you'll back me up on this Sona yeah
it's not an app it's not an act he is a
very irritating fellow I wish it was an
act yeah it's not yeah yeah and he was
for years at our show
um driving people up the wall with his
long pompous explanations of how to make
the best latte and then we just realized
that when I talked to this guy it's kind
of magical and then we've had all these
adventures together over the years and
everyone wants more they want more
Jordan's Leslie but I'm constantly
bumping into people who said my family
and I just did like four hours of you
and Jordan and I think why why would why
would you why would you watch
um me and this very irritating man drive
each other insane but it is pure and uh
I do try to explain that to people yeah
I think that's why it works I don't
think you could make up a person like
Jordan no you recently launched a
channel on Samsung TV and he went to New
York and just handed ice cream out to
people yeah uh and just drove around New
York just handing out ice cream yeah and
I think it was very popular yes it was
uh people really liked it I don't
understand he's been asked because he
has fans like the band Rush really liked
Jordan and Jordan likes rush so they
they asked Jordan to come out and like
open their show by just appearing and
waving
um I'm scared how many common interests
Jordan and I have oh you're a big rush
fan I do love rush you can wow that was
okay what what it sounded judgy like you
were like oh you like Rush okay not at
all okay Getty Lee he's great you can't
just say someone's name in the band to
prove you like the band
anywho
um no no they're they're great they're
in the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame uh
anywho
um Jordan that's the important thing and
uh he's uh not rush and uh he's he's out
there and there'll be more Jordan and he
will re-emerge right now things have
just gotten a little quiet with this uh
Rider strike and they'll remain that way
until it until it gets resolved